[Music]
this is IOT 204 connected robots IOT in
the warehouse
Paul Cap'n Eddie I'm an IOT solutions
engineer with Google hi I'm Christopher
Cacioppo I'm the CTO and one of the
cofounders of 6 river systems 9 joseph
Hughes director of DevOps at 6 river
systems we'll be talking about
collaborative robotics and how it helps
companies meet the ever-changing needs
of today's consumers so quick agenda I'm
gonna take some time initially to try
and frame some of the problems that
warehouses are trying to solve today
I'll also go through through some of the
cloud solutions that help I'll then hand
over to Chris Cacioppo here for a double
click on the business case for
collaborative robotics and a little more
information about six river systems and
then Joe will finish up with all of the
tech behind six river systems and the
products that they offer so there is a
Dory for today's session and I'm told if
you go to the app and go to our session
IOT 204 you can see a link down below
Dory is an internal tool built at Google
that's being made available at next you
can go here to post your questions for
us while we speak you can also see the
questions that others are posting you
can upvote and download those questions
as you see fit
the idea is at the end of the converse
at the end of the presentation we'll
have a bit of a stack ranking of what
the audience wants to hear from us we're
gonna aim to add and 6 minutes 7 minutes
early to try and get as many of these
questions answered as possible and
afterward we'll be able to answer
questions questions offline
so a quick survey so I know who's in the
audience today how many people out there
by show of hands are developers
architects people that are building
systems you have quite a bit that's
great there's definitely content for you
how many people are in the warehouse
space working with warehouse management
systems show of hands got good we got a
bunch how about robotics working with
Ross great there's a bunch of those too
how many people have ever bought a
physical product on the Internet
all right good
captive audience so in all seriousness
this is the audience that we built the
talk for hopefully you find some of this
useful so what are the needs of the
warehouse today and as an IOT developer
that's been working on a lot of
different connected products working
with a lot of different IOT cloud
solutions the first thing that strikes
me is the sheer amount of data available
so there's products there's product
locations there's lidar points there's
all sorts of things that without the
technology you had and now adding robots
you have things like batteries robot
statuses many many many different types
of data and as a person that's managing
a warehouse I want to know that there's
a way of obtaining this data there's a
way of reacting to it formatting it and
Google Cloud has you covered if you're
able to connect your edge devices and
your sensors to cloud IOT core you can
quickly securely and easily get that
data to the cloud from IOT core you get
your data into pub/sub pub/sub can act
as a kind of central point in your cloud
architecture from there you'd be able to
trigger cloud functions to react to your
data or data flows data procs to be able
to try
form your data into an optimal format
and then ultimately sync it to bigquery
and I say bigquery there's a lot of
different data persistence mechanisms
available on data cloud but bigquery I
believe is uniquely well-suited to the
problems warehouses are faced with today
bigquery is Google's server list data
warehouse in the cloud and it's built to
excel with analytics workloads so let's
say you have your data publishing to the
cloud and you have it formatted you have
it synced to bigquery you're quickly
faced with the next daunting task
there's so many things that you could
potentially change in your warehouse to
try and optimize your pick rates or find
bottlenecks or just overall get your
throughput up you could potentially be
spending man months on a part of your
system that even if done purple
perfectly would only shave a small
amount of time off your average pick
rate where there may be a bottleneck
elsewhere that if you've spent a couple
man-hours you would unlock a whole bunch
more throughput the quickest way to get
to this insight is since your data is in
bigquery you can hook it up to data
studio or many of the other business
intelligence suites out there to
visualize your data and understand where
the time is being spent armed with these
visualizations you'd know that spending
man months trying to make your user
interface on your robot more effective
for the picker might not be as impactful
as maybe increasing the speed of your
robot or your object avoidance for your
your slotting of your products because
move time Dwarfs the amount of time that
it takes to pick a product out of a box
so there's a certain level of insight
you could get to with dashboards but to
potentially move beyond you can try and
employ a machine learning machine
learning might uncover different
patterns in the data that might not be
readily apparent with a dashboard or
visualization it also may help in not
only leading you to the opportunities
for improvement but be the improvement
itself you can potentially create models
who can deploy on a robot and have that
robot be more effective in its day to
day job one of the best things about
Google cloud and machine learning on
Google cloud is you don't need an army
of data scientists or tensorflow
developers to be able to start to take
advantage of it since your data's in
bigquery you can use bigquery auto ml to
write a sequel statement that's a
returns your pick times and all of the
different facets that might affect that
pick time and then with two extra
statement two extra lines of code you
can generate a tensor flow model that
forecast snap pick time when you change
some of the other parameters around it
and just like that you might know the
change the effect of the change that you
intend to make under your system you can
take it same data and bigquery and
return robot failures and come up with a
model that gives you predictive
maintenance you can use none of that
data and use a pre-canned model that
would give a robot the ability to see
whether an obstacle in its way is human
or not and for those of you that aren't
in the robotics space this is valuable
because a robot moving very fast in
close proximity to a human would make
that human very uncomfortable very
understandably so but if a robot can't
deduce whether or not a human obstacle
is human it would have to slow down for
every road cone every piece of box or
anything in its way and that could
dramatically impact it in the pic race
so let's say you have your data it's in
the cloud it's in bigquery you have your
visualizations and you started to pick
things that you want to change about
your system to optimize it now you're
faced with another problem because to be
able to get the data you need to
validate those changes are in fact
having a positive impact on your system
could be costly you can't change the
size of your warehouse very easily or
scale up your robot fleet for one day
two three four or five X it's pretty
cost prohibitive to do things like that
so this is where Google kubernetes
engine can help you can spool up
simulated robots and simulated
warehouses and fuel bigquery with the
same types of data you would get if
those robots were real that then fuels
the same dashboards that you used to
pick what optimizations who wanted to
take so this is how you can quickly
validate your change and iterate on to
the next now before i hand over to chris
i wanted to quickly introduce six river
systems six river was founded on the
idea that the technological advantages
that are seen in the the large million
square-foot warehouses by the e-commerce
giants should be available to all so not
only should these robotic systems scale
up very well they should be able to
scale down traditionally to get a fleet
of robots in five hundred thousand
square-foot warehouse you're talking
about six months to twelve months you're
talking about many many years before the
ROI pans out these types of upfront
costs don't work for the 50,000
square-foot warehouse
so six River has a system that can be
installed and up and running in weeks
and fluctuate the size of your fleet for
peak times and get ROI a lot quicker
what they're trying to do is in effect
democratize robotics and level the
playing field with that I'll hand it
over to Chris thank you Paul
so why did we decide to use
collaborative robotics to solve a
warehouse problem and at the end of day
I wanna give you a quick idea of the
problem space and then we'll talk about
that up until about ten years ago
distribution centers were places where
manufacturers bought a lot of cases of
products they were then separated out
and then shipped off to stores to then
fill their socks so there was pretty
much moving cases from place to place
which is reasonably easy to automate
there nice touch and square and it
doesn't require a ton of labor but in
the last ten years things have changed
when you guys order things online you
never want to case a toothbrushes you
want a toothbrush and a toothpaste maybe
an iPad and some diapers right they're
all differ for everybody and so it
requires a little break me open cases
taking things apart dealing with odd
shaped items and so the warehouse does
look more like this so there are people
working on automatic hands and arms and
you've probably seen picking challenges
and they always took off nice clean pick
faces but it's clearly for us at least
five or ten years off before they have
robotic arms and go in take things apart
pull things together gift wrap all that
south requires laborious there's a
tremendous labor impact for the
foreseeable future in this area to make
matters worse when I was a kid I it was
my birthday my mom will you order
something the Sears catalog and we've
mail it in and it would take six to
eight weeks to show up and I would have
forgotten what it was but I'm sure was
excited to get it anyway well in the 90s
early 2000s shipping time for about two
weeks he ordered something online for
early e-commerce they show up in two
weeks everyone was happy it was great
but today's day and age people expect
things entry-level as two day shipping
then it's like one day and like it'd be
nice to be sure there's an afternoon and
so the pressure that puts on to fulfill
centers to get things out the door is
tremendous so like many things as
latency goes down the efficiencies get
worse and so there's even more pressure
on labor these fulfillment centers and
distribution centers are located in
places where land is inexpensive and
before there was didn't need a lot of
labor but they've kind of sucked up all
the available labor I was with a
customer about two weeks ago and they
said it's not so much I care about the
price of labor they'll try to do its
that I literally can't get people to
reliably show up anymore I could get
enough people to do so what we've done
is to solve this problem with with Chuck
and Chuck do I come over here so Chuck
is is dressed up in its Google best
Chuck it's a collaborative robotic robot
and the thing I want to point out here
is this makes the the associates lives
much easier but everyone in our company
is super excited about robots and I
think most people in this talk would
think robots are pretty cool some
cameras out there so that's pretty cool
but people that are often associated
working warehouses robots can be scary
for a number of reasons and so one of
the things we did is when I started this
I didn't want a little circle or
rectangle or square in a warehouse that
wasn't obviously was gonna do so I put
on my in Dussel an additional
engineering hat and said okay we got a
good designer and said I want this to be
obvious so this is Cleavon modeled after
a car it's got Ted headlights and
taillights it looks like a car and when
you look at it you know in here things
could go that way it's gonna go that way
and if it backs up which it does very
rarely it's gonna beep and look like a
truck so we want to do is get people
comfortable with the concept so that
they're comfortable if people are not
comfortable work with your collaborative
robotics they're not going to use it and
nothing's gonna work well so we've had
very good luck and everyone loves using
our robots
so the way a typical warehouse works for
car pick operations an associate will
walk over to an inductor area with a big
heavy cart and they'll put a whole bunch
of boxes on it and get a whole bunch of
paper tickets and walk over to their
pickin racks it to look like Costco or a
backing from Ikea or Sam's Club except
much more dense they're then gonna walk
up and down Tahoma tiles for filling the
order so these paper tickets and finding
everything where they remember and
they're gonna bring it over to a takeoff
area or possibly multiple ones and
there's a big loop okay at six River we
decided what's most important that the
associates can do is that much better
than anyone else it's the grass in the
hand so we want to try to alleviate as
much of the other stuff to doing as
possible and these aren't small places
as we talked about these are 500k 50k to
500k or more warehouse is there
tremendous amount of movement so what
our system does is there's a person who
sits in an indepth area on top and they
put work on the robot and then the robot
takes off okay the robot will then meet
someone in the picking area they will
then walk with them through the area
showing the pictures taken from place to
place and the best method possible and
then where they're done that robot will
take off and deliver it to multiple
places essentially and another what we
waiting for them so we'll keep them
localized in doing what they do best in
the picking aisles what we can do is
improve pick rates two to three x over
traditional car pick okay and we do this
by number ways we reduce the long walk
some people to walk across giant
warehouses we have very effectively pick
orders that go together in a nice clean
way so they walk as little as possible
we pick them awfully from place to place
and we also have very clean you eyes
which lets them get the data fast and
they can pick faster they can lower
error rates and they can ruse training
time from weeks to hours and this has
been hugely positive our customers
the next thing about Chuck that's very
interesting is it's a disruptive
technology so there's a number of
technologies out there that allow car
picking that enhance carpet or replace
carpeting so but most of these
operations have three to five years ROI
and are bolted in the floor and I don't
know about anyone in this audience but I
have no idea my cup is going to be in
three to five years like technology
changed so fast it is a tremendous
investment to do to make matters worse
there's generally in this industry
there's a huge seasonal change so right
around holiday season most of our
customers see a three to 7x change in
their operation right tremendous changes
so not only do you have to predict
potentially five or more years in the
future but you also have to scale up so
that your operation is running pretty
much at peak to peak time and then
eighty percent of your time it's
significantly under utilized so what we
allow it happen is we have a two to one
year ROI for our products they can
instead of being installed a lot of
opera most automation is six months to a
year of installation time we get up and
running in one or two weeks okay it also
allows you to scale your operation if
your operations getting more and more
going up and up you just buy more robots
we just deliver them they work as is if
your operations feelin's scaling down
well if you've another DC or another
fulfillment center just move the robots
if you have seasonality just instead of
building our system from six River that
works for your peak for the entire year
just build for your average for the air
and we'll leash you more robots for your
peak time so we allow a tremendous
amount of flexibility that it's just not
possible anywhere else in the tree so
from the first day I sat down on the my
dining room table of my two other
co-founders to the day we had a small
fleet of collaborative robots picking
live order to blues toys and a customer
warehouse was nine months which is
looking back on it felts much longer but
it's an amazing feat and I don't think
this is possible
ten years ago even with the the best
group of people you could ask and the
reason is I think there's three key
technologies for the last 10 years that
have made a tremendous change
one is ubiquitous computing power so
we've invested invidious jetsons tx2
platform until that gives a tremendous
amount of processing power at very low
energy consumption and a reasonable
pipelines and so we've done a lot of
work with them but it's not just that
it's all the centers and all the things
that allow robotics to work have come
down tremendously in price it wasn't
that long ago that the spinning lighters
you see on top of the Google cars they
cost like 50 grams but and now we can
have one to the robot that cost less
than a thousand so there's a huge change
of technology that allows that's
enabling things that just weren't
possible for the second one is open
source so I'm sure everyone here uses
it's gotten better and better over the
last ten years I want to call up Ross
Ross is Colt is a robot operating system
for your non robot assists it allows you
to bootstrap robots really fast so you
can focus on the things that your
business cares about and not focusing on
the plumbing and infrastructure so we
could very quickly get a robot up and
working and then pile more stuff on
topic to optimize it for our
environments and last but not least is
ubiquitous cloud platforms and we've
embraced Google cloud from day one this
allows you to like scale the operations
leverage your engineers we have do a lot
of testing stuff we have a lot of
security things it just allowed us to go
so much faster than we would have
otherwise so given the audience I think
what's been the rest of the time talking
about the Google cloud so one thing
that's very important to me personally
is data-driven decisions pretty much
this entire conference is about data
right and so collecting data and
everyone knows data is good but how do
you use data how do you make it
effective for you so let me go through
some of the ways and we use it and we
have a lot of data both from a logistics
side and also from the robot side if you
have a workers robots robots generate a
tremendous amount of data and make lots
of decisions and it's very hard to turn
through all the data otherwise the first
thing we do is operational intelligence
we have a ton of data on all of our
customers operation and we can tell them
how much work they're doing how much
time they have left the rates they do
things a whole bunch up we can say which
which of
Associates imploring better and worse
but even more than that
instead of saying Chris is
underperforming I could say Chris seems
we doing pretty well he's just really
slow at scanning maybe he doesn't have
that section works and to associate can
come to me and help coach me through
something that I'm weak act as opposed
to just dealing with it or deciding they
should get to my other employee if
that's even possible the next thing is
visualizing data this is one of my
favorite things so this up here is a
picture of a robot go through the
warehouse all the time they report back
wireless signal strength constantly so
every second or so and so this is a map
of the wireless signal strength at
various ports the warehouse so people do
wireless surveys and they're sort of ad
hoc and occasionally happen we are
constantly real-time showing a wireless
survey of the warehouse so you can tell
them this warehouse is a big area in the
center that's probably pretty weak and
if the customer cares they should
probably update that but I think what's
more important is how we use it for our
internal engineering personally so when
you're starting to build a robot you get
a robot and you get wave to you first
you have to make it move
check it moves and then we don't just
want to move we want to move from A to B
so we want to move over there excellent
check we have to have a to be and then
you want it not to hit things all right
check and you go through this whole list
of things whether it's robots or any
product you guys do until you get an MVP
and it's in front of the customer at
that point it's great we get some
feedback and we work on the most
important things next how do we choose
the most important things in most
operations it's done at one of three
ways one the manager or whoever is in
charge decides to the loudest engineer
decides or three if you're doing things
probably correctly you have a consensus
of engineers that decide together but
the problem is even in the even a latter
case we have a consensus it doesn't mean
you're working on the right thing or
most important thing first you just all
agree you could all agree on the wrong
thing so this is a graph up here about
the time that the associates are
spending on our product which is
important of of labor management and
labor savings so the big blue box here
is movement
says the large amount of time about 44%
is spent on the robot moving from point
A to point B with the associate in
intohe there are other things down here
too just scanning right and so one of
our interns may have a great idea we can
just remove scanning entirely and that
sounds like a great idea we can just
skip that step and be awesome let's work
on that and someone else have an idea it
says we can reduce movement 20%
that doesn't sound is good but if you
look at the numbers it's way better to
spend time reducing move it by 20% and
is removing a stage even though it
doesn't intuitively feel like just
removing something isn't just a better
idea so I'm gonna give an example that
this is another customer warehouse and
instead of plotting Wi-Fi signal
strength we're putting average movement
speed of the robots so you can see right
a slower green is faster so if you look
at some of this and analyze a little bit
at the end of aisles things are slowing
down it makes sense there's there's
cross traffic there's blind turn so you
gotta be a little more careful around
that but they're slower is in the middle
of the aisles but doesn't make a lot of
sense right robots should be humming
along they're to be fine so we can do
two things here and we do both them one
is we can push back into customers and
say hey you guys should clean this up
the robots move faster and your rates to
go up
but really it's better of like why are
we slowing down like so because
everybody wants a robot suit faster so I
think obviously the next thing we do is
just make the robots top speed faster or
is it so silver engineers Chuck's over
robots and put it in a test track and
instead of just reporting the maximum
speed in robots they report the internal
choices of robots and essentially crash
course in robotics here we have a bunch
of different tasks that determine how
fast a robot can go and the slowest one
wins because we believe in safety and
everything else
so whatever chooses the slowest and
that's the one that we go at so if you
look up here red says I'm near an
obstacle yellow says go top speed so if
you look up there and we increase our
top speed really wouldn't have had a
giant impact on our robot right now
because mostly we're having around
objects and we're slowing ourselves down
because we're being extra careful so the
engineers took this data in tackling
that problem instead of trying to make
the robot respond faster to go faster
and analyze that problem and after a
couple weeks they did the test track
again and this is what they got you'll
notice instead of being like 85% red
it's not like 40% red and there's a lot
of it yellow which is the top speed the
robots just cruising along at top speed
so there was a huge impact of diving
into this problem and Ulta about a 15%
movement speed increase and now that the
interiors can look at this and say okay
should we keep pushing on that problem
should we look at that at the teal over
here which is a pathing issue should we
think about raising top speed but it
allows a data-driven decision when
obviously - everyone says we should just
make the robots move faster and that was
actually the wrong decision so that's my
part of the talk I'm gonna hand off to
Joe who makes all the magic happen here
thanks Chris so you just got hired at
the next IOT robotics company and you
wake up the next day you're feeling good
but then you think to yourself I need a
robot infrastructure lucky for you
you're here Google cloud next and we're
gonna help you understand how we've used
Google cloud to address some of the most
challenging aspects of this problem the
first and most obvious problem is you
have all this data you have hundreds of
robots in the field you have robots that
are in your test environments and your
customer environments you have to get
all this data and you have to make some
sort of sense out of it so we're gonna
talk about this slide for the next 30
minutes all right you guys didn't run
away we're not gonna do that but I think
here there's an important thing that I
want to point out about this
architecture we don't just use cloud IOT
core for everything we also use Google
Storage for a couple of things and the
reason we do that is that there's some
data that is really important to have in
real time but there's other data that we
may need later that is really dense and
and Chris talked a little bit about that
data that's your lidar scans your point
clouds the robot Isis if you're not a
roboticist that's really kind of what
the robot is seeing and vlogging all of
that and we need to put that into Google
storage because those files are big
they're dense
then we need to run it and break it down
so we make heavy use of pub/sub and
cloud functions to massage that data get
it into the format that we can consume
some of that data comes all the way back
through to a web you know a web page
where people can consume it some of that
data goes to bigquery and that's what
drives some of those interesting graphs
that Chris showed you before what we're
going to be doing next is using that
data in bigquery as as Paul alluded
earlier to drive some machine learning
models so we can get better and think
more about the data that we're
collecting but this this infrastructure
for us this design has survived the test
of time and scaled with us with no
intervention engineering intervention at
all so the so one of the things that you
want from this data is real-time
location you may think to yourself well
what that seems important but I'm gonna
explain to you why it's very important
if you're managing a million square-foot
warehouse and you can't have
line-of-sight to everything so you need
a bird's eye view of what's going on you
have 25 trucks in the field you might
have 50 employees in the field and you
really need that real-time feedback so
most obviously you just need to know
where Chuck's are if you can only see 10
trucks at a time you need to know where
the other 10 are and make sure they're
doing the things that you expect that
they should be doing in your warehouse
you also want to see if chucks in
trouble you'll see two trucks here
blinking red if a warehouse manager was
to click on one of those they could see
that there's an obstacle in Chuck's way
or that there's some other unexpected
event maybe some sort of maintenance
that needs to be done to chuck in any
case it really calls out very clearly
that there's a problem it needs to be
resolved they can get on a radio talk to
someone and ask them what the problem is
or they can make the decision to walk
over but if you're constantly walking
around a million square foot warehouse
looking for problems most likely you're
not going to be able to find them lastly
you want to understand the operation so
if you see Chuck's queueing up in a
weird way or you see that chucks and
your your operators are not in the right
part of the warehouse
for where they need to be at that point
of the day then you can correct that and
make sure that your rates you still hit
your rates and that means that everyone
in the audience gets their shoes on time
or their toothbrushes on time or
whatever you might be ordering off the
internet the next big thing that you
want from all this data is real-time
monitoring our customers run 24/7
the Internet's up 24/7 people are
ordering 24/7 and you expect your stuff
in two days so we have a tech support
team that also runs 24/7 and when
something comes in they need to really
quickly respond now for our cloud
software that's running in the cloud
stackdriver was a clear choice out of
the box gave us alerting it gave us all
the monitoring that we could possibly
want and we didn't have to invest any
engineering time into instrumenting
which came with the platform we use
Google core IOT to feed data into influx
DB for time series database and then
also drive the dets dashboards like you
see behind me this gives us our CPU
metrics our memory metrics and our
temperature metrics some of these
warehouses get up to over 100 degrees so
the temperature of their CPU becomes
super important your fan fails and your
CPUs overheating you're gonna have a
very unhappy robot and eventually you'll
have a very unhappy customer but this
really all drives preventative
maintenance if we can take a chuck out
of service before it fails and clogs up
the works then we can save our customer
time they may be running a degraded
system for a little bit but hopefully we
can pull the chuck out of service
replace apart from a spare part kit and
get Chuck back in and doing its job
lastly when we touched on this little
earlier but enabling technical support
super important they're really the front
line of defense and they need tools to
help the customer resolve their problems
quickly and not interrupt engineering if
engineers are spending all their time
solving customer issues in the field
then they're not going to be able to
build the next great feature and make
Chuck better and we're constantly doing
the experiments like Chris showed you
earlier to make Chuck faster and to
continually raise our customers rates
through just software
and better engineering practices so this
is the second type of data that we were
talking about in that architecture slide
this is data that's not really valuable
in real time from every single Chuck
because it's very dense and it's very it
gives you the whole picture of what
Chuck sees in the world but you may want
this data because you want to replay
Chuck travel you get a something from
the field and say hey Chuck is moving
strangely around this shelf or Chuck
can't see this particular thing on the
ground or something of that nature and
that comes to our engineering team and
we need to be able to see that and so we
have two options we can get on a plane
we can fly over the warehouse go take a
look at Chuck and say oh well I guess I
can hook in and take a look at the
sensors or maybe it's not even doing
that anymore by the time you get there
but planes are expensive and engineering
time is also expensive or you can replay
this truck Chuck travel from Google
Cloud you pull that down and you can
replay in real time so what you're
seeing on the right of this is you can
actually see Chuck seeing other chucks
on the left you can see shelfs that's
what's called a point cloud you can see
it's made up of a lot of points from
this our engineers can deduce a lot of
interesting things there's your test
environment what you have in your
warehouse where you do all your tests
and you try really hard to make Chuck
move the right way all the time
inevitably though you get out into the
field and there's things you didn't
expect these you know we call the
movement issues they're caused by some
interesting things some customers shine
their floors so or they have skylights
and that feeds back into the sensors and
makes this point cloud much different
than it does look at our headquarters on
our test track help improve efficiency
Chris kind of alluded to this earlier
but if there's a specific specific place
in the warehouse where the Chuck's just
always move slow sometimes what we can
do is clearly just see that the wide R
or the camera is seeing something that
it shouldn't and with a little bit of
adjustment by the customer or a little
bit of adjustment in the map that we use
to navigate we can
alleviate those problems so you have all
your data but now you have a hundred a
thousand a million robots in the fields
and you need to upgrade them at some
point so how do you do that traditional
software management ansible saltstack
puppet they're great tools for managing
servers you have an always great
internet connection and you always and
you and you can kind of rely on either a
connection to you know make things good
for you the great white whale of Chuck
is reliable Wi-Fi warehouses just don't
have reliable Wi-Fi there's a lot of
racks there's a lot of interference and
so what we end up with is half applied
States so almost worse than an upgrade
just failing is a half upgrade an
upgrade that looks like it went good but
it didn't go all the way and we battled
a lot of these problems early on so we
said to ourself there has to be a better
way you have to be able to reduce the
complexity of these things we have to be
able to be be able to minimize than the
amount of data that's being pulled down
and do it more deterministic so we
shoehorned everything into docker docker
containers are pretty great at solving
this problem if you have a container it
either downloads or it doesn't if you
need to roll back your roll back to a
different container you have a very good
view of the world of where your software
is updating and so if you need to update
a thousand of these things you all you
need is a good internet connection to
download a single file versus what you
would have to do in the other situation
which is a bit of a back-and-forth
between a lot of different services we
really leverage Google cloud platform to
make this possible and don't get scared
it's another architecture slide but
we're gonna go for it quickly Google has
to go a lot of great tools for building
containers cloud builds scales with our
developers as they need to make
containers and we're rushing to finish
releases then you know we can have 20
developers doing 20 different builds and
Google Cloud builder scales up we push
all those to the container registry and
then then we have our custom solution to
this problem but
really Google has a great toolkit with
kubernetes engine that you can run
software that that just consumes a lot
of this stuff
and finally this software allows us to
push things out through IOT core IOT
core can't just collect data but it can
actually manage the configuration of the
robots so essentially the message goes
out to one a thousand a million robots
saying we need you to download this
container from container registry and
then they go into action so I'm gonna
show you how that works here's an actual
upgrade so let's just sped up a little
bit but these containers download the
the robot gets the command gives us the
does it the signal that it downloaded
and then we can apply that upgrade and
so you'll see we do three at a time here
they download and they apply and so
we're taking three trucks out of service
we're downloading a container that
container gets applied they go back into
service but we know exactly if it if
something didn't work if it did work and
the nice thing is going from build X to
build Y it's just as easy as going from
build wide back to build X because I
think all of us know that sometimes
software upgrades don't go well so
almost as important as your upgrade path
is your downgrade path but with docker
kubernetes to drive this to drive this
software and IOT core we can really
manage this problem very well so we have
all the data we have thousands of robots
and now our customer comes and says to
us hey we think we need to rearrange our
entire warehouse we have 100 trucks and
we think that this design might work
better and you're like ok well so we're
back into kind of a problem here so we
can either fly out to the warehouse
bring another 100 trucks get another
warehouse set it up the way they want
test and make sure that it works or we
have to do something else and I think we
all kind of realized we pretty much just
have to do something else so going back
to our docker adventure here we
we were really pleased when we got to
this point when we said okay we already
have everything in docker so all we
really need to do is change a few things
in this container and we'll actually
have a docker container that can be run
in a simulated world so we have the
robot operating system running
completely inside of the docker
container all we do is simulate the
sensor data and so what's really
powerful about this is that the sensor
data coming in is going through the same
pipeline that it would go through in the
real world so as we make adjustments we
can be very confident that those
adjustments are going to behave the way
that we expect them to in the real world
and that really just gives us that extra
bit here where things are things when we
go to deploy them behave they're the way
that we want so why would we want to
test with hundreds of robots the
warehouse layout change is one thing but
another thing is algorithm changes you
know we have a lot of logic and
algorithms as Chris alluded to earlier
that batch orders and to try to gain
more efficiencies in the warehouse and
so when we change those algorithms it's
not really great for us to test them out
on a customer because you can imagine
what a customer's gonna call us and say
they're gonna call us and say hey Joe
that software upgrade you gave me now my
rates just fell by 50% and that's not a
really great conversation to have and
that's not what we want to do for our
customers and so with this sort of
infrastructure we can prove algorithm
changes before we deploy them and we can
confidently tell a customer when you
take this release you're gonna get X
number of X percent of improvement
you're Pickers will be this much more
efficient your warehouse will be able to
get this many orders out the door and be
very confident that's an accurate
estimate and lastly and I think which is
kind of an interesting way to use the
system is that we have cloud systems as
well and we can do synthetic load
testing in those cloud systems and throw
you know
fubar data at it or we can run real
robots again real simulated robots
against that system and do load tests
for warehouses that are even
impractical to build in the physical
world so we can really put our other
software and the cloud through the paces
using a very large deployment of
simulated chucks so scaling with
kubernetes engine is super easy auto
scaling works great and that is really
important for this problem you don't
want to have to call up DevOps engineer
and say hey I need a cluster with 100
simulated chucks you just want to tell
your software I need 107 simulated
chucks and then minutes later you have a
hundred simulated chucks stackdriver
monitoring is built in and so you can
see your simulated chucks and see trends
in their CPU usage their memory usage
and see all of that and feed it into
bigquery as Paul alluded earlier and
make sure that your dashboards perform
the way that they should and that you're
seeing the algorithm improvements that
you should you can scale up and down
quickly scaling up is super quick
scaling down is also super quick because
this is expensive resource and you don't
want to be spending money with a
simulation cluster that someone forgot
to shut down for like a weekend and your
Google Cloud bill all of a sudden is a
little bit higher than you expect it so
here's a real simulation this is a
pretend warehouse in the cloud we have
pretend robots running around doing
robot things they're picking orders
they're inducting orders they're even
they even go to charge they even have
simulated batteries so because charging
can actually take out of the efficiency
of the system so we simulate all of that
and we can put all the things I talked
about into this and so very very
flexible system
another thing that happens is that when
you start simulating things if you spawn
20 robots in the corner of a warehouse
they kind of form a mosh pit and they
don't really do very well and so these
are some of the fun things that you
start to discover when you build a
simulation platform is like oh wait a
second they all can't just spawn in one
place they need to actually spawn at
randoms points and we need to kind of
figure out how we scale this up and down
but yeah that's a fun little video of a
robot mosh pit if you ever wanted to see
one so the last thing we need to talk
about is integrating with your customers
you didn't just build this robotic IOT
platform for yourself you built it
because you wanted to bring it to the
world and you want people to use it and
companies to use it and so you have to
kind of discover who your customers are
discover what kind of technology they
have and and you have to integrate with
it so in traditional in warehouse man
warehouse management systems are the
systems that handle all the orders
handle all the inventory they kind of
determine like what that day's picking
is going to be and they give us our work
and so we have to innovate with them our
customers I have older systems there in
the logistics business they're not in
the IT or the tech business and so when
they find a solution that works for them
they stay with that solution and and we
want we don't want to go into our
customers and say well we wish we could
work with you but you have to update all
of your IT systems to adhere to you know
rest standards or into our api's we have
to do something different so we adapt
artists our rest api's to our customers
technology they use socket communication
with fixed with messages are you soap
they use SFTP I mean they use everything
and so that means we have to build
everything and we have to adapt our
api's to everything and so that's a big
challenge but luckily when you're using
Google cloud platform you have a lot of
tools at your fingertips to help you
with that challenge we reach for cloud
functions for the simplest of
integrations and kubernetes also makes
super quick with things like hey native
and other tools that are coming to the
kubernetes platform well we can build
these little micro services like their
only purpose in life is to translate our
API messages so that our customers can
understand them there's a lot of
challenges still with but with these
tools without these tools we wouldn't be
able to do what we do today at the pace
and at the scale we do it today Google
kubernetes engine on prim is the next
great thing that six our river systems
is really looking at and some of our
customers have such tight regulation you
can think government and those type of
things where they just don't have the
option to have anything outside of their
four walls and so with these type of
deployments we're really excited to
experiment and to use Google Cooper nazy
on Prem to solve these problems so you
know these these regulation and concerns
are definitely one part of it another
part it's of like bringing the sensitive
sent latency sensitive things that need
to happen to the edge and the edge being
the customers own infrastructure and so
if we have to validate something every
single time we scan it and we can't
afford the trip up to our cloud back to
their data center back to chuck then
some system like this makes things a lot
easier for the customer and for us to
get that integration done and to really
have a great customer experience from
our point of view it's so great that we
can have the same deployment tooling
that manages all of our normal cloud
deployments
these on-prem deployments as well and so
that can reduce our overhead for you
know DevOps tooling and for and to keep
the interface that we use for our
software engineers and for our tech our
tech support engineers the same
[Music]